Rebels!
She started so early!
Oh my god, a full five minutes early!
Oh my god!
What's so wild.
Anyway, guys, hello everybody and welcome to the early access of season five for Marvel Rivals.
A huge shout out again to Marvel Rivals for sponsoring me on today's stream.
I am the VTuber representation for the early access amongst all the fleshy's that will be streaming it today so um yay yippee i really am very honored to be chosen um to uh to be the show the early access showcase for the vtuber side uh it really does mean a lot um anyway for this don't know your uh marvel revival season five will be launching on november 14th um gambit is the new hero for this season or not this season next season technically next season in like days so um it will be gambit yes we are all very surprised that he is a support character um i don't think anyone expected that not even me because you know we also see gambit as like you know sort of like dps you know because he has like cards does explosions and stuff like that yeah i think a lot of us expected to dps dps so everyone was like oh man another dps and then guango was like psych support like jokes on you Support!
Yeah, explosives.
The most supportive skill.
Yeah.
So, so no one expected that.
And it was a very nice surprise.
But yeah, you guys didn't know.
This game basically has updates almost every month, which is crazy.
Not like a hero every month is crazy.
And I think you guys might know season 5.5 would be rogue because it's based on Gambit and Rogue since they're married.
Everything so I'm surprised.
I don't think they're I don't think rogue's gonna be another support But my theory is okay, you're gonna see this.
I'm gonna show the trailer and I think My theory is that she's gonna be a tank because in the trailer You see right next to Emma and they are the same size.
I was like oh my gambit bro Bro man you scored bro.
He just wants to be crushed by giant women like bit one bro like yeah yeah so we're gonna watch uh a trailer two trailers real quick um i did watch them before but we'll blind react to them again not blind sorry i'll react to it again because like it's funny everyone's like when was the trailer dropped because no one you know everyone expected to be last week so if you guys didn't watch the trailer um here is the trailer choice but not a doubt moment yeah because like wolverine's like oh you should like look at look at driving the motorcycle.
Bro.
Okay, look at this.
This is why I think Rogue is going to be a tank because she's bigger than Emma.
Like, she's literally bigger than Emma.
So I feel like she has to be a tank because there's no way they're releasing two supports at the same time.
Yeah, and Magneto's in the shot, too.
Like, all the two tank players are there.
Just lucky motherfucker.
He's she's a but she has to be a muscle mommy.
I I she has to be a tank.
There's no way I don't think it'll release two some like two supports in a row.
That's way too wild Making gambit a support is already a lot.
Also, I can't really try to make Loki and Mantis his cannon in the Marvel Ravos Universe.
Oh my god, there's Cyclops
They released two DPS before yes, but DPS players are greedy
supports supports will take anything they could get DPS players are greedy as hell all right and then here is the gambit trailer oh yes there he is I have tried gambit a little bit upstream because I have to like you know prepare everything to make sure everything works and he is so overwhelming as support you guys will understand the moment I show you guys his util you will understand he is so he is very Like there is a lot of,
I swear to God, if I see a raccoon player, that's not me, that's trying to play this character, it's GG's.
Like, I do not believe in my cloak slash raccoon player to pick up Gambit because I looked at Gambit and I was like, oh my, you have to know resource management very well.
yeah if i know if i see a cloak main or a rocket man trying to pick up this guy it's it's ggs he is very high maintenance yeah of course he's he knows french he's always known french guys he's always known french someone was like why is there french music i'm like because gambit speaks french he always goes like mon ami it's been that way until the end of time um it's very oh yeah apparently for um um the voice actors for gambit and rogue they've been the they got the people they got for gambit and rogue they've always voice acted them uh well not the rogue the last time the voice actress did rogue she did the marvel versus capcon um um and she like and then like she came back to voice her again but i know that gambit person the one who does gambit he's been voicing gambit for years basically for almost every like iteration of him so I thought that was really cool that they got them um because a lot of the other voice actors they're like new voice actors for these characters but for
Gambit and Rogue um they've been getting they got like the reoccurring voice actors yeah um but anyway alright let's go check let me make sure uh alright let's look at Gambit and the battle pass the real content alright um also like for those who don't know they buffed a lot of things they joined zero things and buffed everything so like i need you guys to give me a list of what to check up because i looked at the the rivals list and i was like i don't know it was like seven plus characters and i was just like i don't know i can't keep track of it i need you guys to tell me what to check out i was like that's a lie that's like i can count to three that's it um all right let's see oh yeah but here's the new skin for oh no game audio all right here you go here's the new skin for gambit pretty cool pretty neat yeah i already bought it by the way also magnino gets everything goddamn he also gets a new skin there's like his highlight intro i i honestly i don't know the default one is such a
classic it's just the problem with me and new skins it looks so cool but like when i look at like classic like marvel characters like gambit it's so hard to go from default because it's such a classic design so it's it's so difficult i don't care about magneto though you can be in whatever skin he wants but his classic one is so iconic so it's so hard for me to swap anyway so um namor gets a powdered skin it's like um i like that it's sort of like pious pious of the caribbean And he looks like Davy Jones.
Yeah, it's like...
Yeah, it's like Davy Jones.
I like that.
And then there's his emote for it.
Davy Jones Locker.
And then there's the pilot intro.
Ooh, that looks sick.
I like how his crew is actually just like...
It's just an octopus.
Like, why are you wearing an odd patch?
Why are you wearing an odd patch?
Oh yeah, I was so surprised that I was surprised that Groot doesn't have the guardian skin I thought because everyone has a guardian skin except for Groot But they gave him that now Look at that Look He has his little plane Here comes the airplane Yeah Naked Groot is peak Groot Um Uh,
Zal, think about the tier 1 sub Thank you.
I'll kindly thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
We are Groot.
Oh my God.
We.
Oh yeah.
There's the Frankenstein.
Wait.
There's Frankenstein Punisher.
That's what it called.
Frankencastle.
And then there's.
I think the highlight intro is cool as fuck though.
No.
Okay.
The highlight is really cool.
I like the highlight intro.
I think it's cool that he's like bursting out of the TV.
Okay.
And then, okay, blue...
I remember I saw this.
I was like, it's thing, but he's blue.
It's perfect.
And this one is from...
I think this one has to be from the movie.
We're in the fantastic...
Why are he's blue?
It's like a blue rock.
Yeah, I...
Okay, it's a good skin, but I have a feeling...
Okay, unless it's the...
which one was it it's the ultron cricoa map because that one's pretty blue but like i feel like in any other map i can see where he is like 80 miles away he's so blue bro what if he was blue though oh yeah wait it's from what if guys it first appears when what if what if the thing were blue so it's just like bro guys what if he was blue guys just what if oh yeah this one i was like this one was a surprise because like oh yeah um basically she is a dps healer now she can shoot people to heal and then um i was like i was like that's cool she can be like a third support and then like and now sinking like we all know widow mains aren't even gonna shoot someone I feel like widow mains aren't even gonna bother shooting someone even if they have the like even though they have the ability to I don't think like real widow maize will even try wait
yeah she can out heal ultrons now she can actually out heal ultron which is crazy um but yeah I was I was not expecting this because I was like it did not look like widow yeah it's is healing like what is this a d someone picking widow is not here to heal she is not here for healing okay and then like there's white hella it's a very clean skin the skin is pretty clean that's her 60 i didn't realize in the 60s she looks like that is i never expect her to have blue hair i've always like associated red hair with widow oh this one's sick i was not expecting Angela she turned into a furry I was surprised it just didn't have this was like not like a uh what is it like a full legendary skin oh
that's crazy I was not expecting this like oh she has furry abs like that's how ripped she is like because fur is supposed to hide the abs when you look at the tiger you don't see like abs but like she's so jacked up that even the fur can't cover the abs yeah oh yeah and also damn like right here she built like a brick like a brick house yeah god damn all right and then there's oh yeah this one's i this one's really clean.
I like this one.
Infinity Ultron?
I'm gonna grab that.
I personally think this one's super clean.
Yeah, I like this one more.
And this is my favorite Ultron skin so far.
Yeah, this Ultron is sick.
He got bling.
Got the Infinity Ultron.
Is this from What If?
I think my favorite is like, what if the thing was blue?
Oh yeah, by the way, Adam finally got some I read that like someone was like it's been X amount of days since Adam got a skin Are you all happy now?
Now he's purple There he is yes Adam has finally got a skin guys is guys reset the counter reset the counter He's purple now Consider they give him the five gifted souls.
Thank you.
Purple Adam.
Yeah, what if Adam was purple?
uh
Apparently it's like one of like his original like before he was good he was herbal because I guess like um That was like the perfect being had to be purple at first Also, Annie, thank you for the rate.
Thank you.
We had a great stream Everyone do we check out the early access of season five.
All right, so here's the new wand This is like a classic wand of skin, too have to say for wanda is sometimes very hard to like tell when wanda has a new skin because it's all red so like i always get very confused oh hello what is this preview yeah this one's a classic wanda skin i'm pretty sure oh there's like new new stuff for it too
what what the
I don't play Wanda's nothing looks so it all looks this oh wait oh it's like a skeleton like the sound effects is different yeah it's like skeletons oh it's more spooky scary I noticed it yeah it's her original outfit all right so oh this is nice that's a nice app banner and then here's the
was blue.
Guys, but what if one that was blue, though?
True.
That was the for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Guys, they should make it all so that they're all blue.
I want to see them all be blue.
Oh, yeah, so there's a freebie.
Basically, all of them can sit down.
So when Season 5 comes out on November 14th, By the way, remember to click on the link to play Marvel Rivals right now.
You can download the game right now.
And it's free.
We all love it when it's free.
But you can, um, look, oh my god, this is so cute, actually.
This should be an April Fool's Day.
What if they're all just blue?
Yeah, it looks like you hit detention.
You're being sent to the, and they each have their own, like, little special poses and everything.
Um, so I thought that was, like, really cute.
I know some have their own like idle animation as well.
Oh my god, Loki, you're so...
You're so much.
God, you're a lot.
Oh yeah, and also Spider-Man too.
Spider-Man paint now.
Oh, I can't get it.
But yeah, Spider-Man also has a new skin and everything.
I think that's all the cosmetics and everything.
Let me double check.
Oh yeah, there's new accessories too.
So everyone has new accessories too.
I mean, I guess I could buy it.
I mean, I have the money.
So extra.
I normally never equip these.
Because, like, for me, it's, like, I find it.
Like, I personally, like, don't like equipping them.
But, um, but I'll do it for today.
For early access for those who want to see it.
Oh, my God.
He has this little alligator.
Yeah, he has a little one-of-a-kind music player.
Uh, yeah, they have a little...
I know they do a little effect.
They, like, cheer you on and stuff when you get a kill.
Because I know...
Oh!
Wolverine is the his daughter.
Okay, that's cute.
I like that Wolverine is his daughter.
All right, let's go.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I can't go to the I can't go to time square yet, guys.
That's when we hang out with the other streamers.
All right, let me check what time do we go to town's time square.
Okay, we have plenty of time.
All right.
Gambit.
Okay.
I'll let you guys look.
So all right.
I will be left side jokie just for this.
Oh, yeah, for sorry.
I forgot to show.
you guys this real quick too um the lord icon i know some people want no one knows about the lord icon so where is he there he is so um he has a four star which you know we all know why he's a four star right so this is a defawe we already saw the mvp though but we all know why he's a four star it's it's it's a lot uh there's some of his emotes and then his other one where he gets to scroll out and everything whoa okay so um you don't see any of this yet but i will show you why i'm like so this is his lord icon right here default lord default lord all right i'll show you why he is very overwhelming to play and i shall be left side doki so you guys can all see the hundreds of cooldowns you got resource management you gotta do um i think like when you get obviously when you get a hang of it then it won't be as difficult but like it's still like it was a lot it was it was a lot all right so you see this you see the four cards in front of you So,
obviously, he can do damage on his primary And then he can also heal So, he can do damage like that And then he can heal here, like, like that So, like, here, I'll show you This is once, there's page one And then there's page two
There's page one and page two So, uh, God, he's so cool Pottence and thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
So I'm surprised he's not five stars.
So um it's time to read guys.
So what's cool about this is that he does have he does have this dash thing.
You guys see that?
And the thing about that is that you can dash anywhere.
But without the dash it's just a right click like this.
So you can do that without the dash but obviously you can do normal dash too so it does damage when you do the combo um so like if i want to do a combo it'll be like it'll be like what was it okay what is it was like like that so you have to do shift right-click so you can do damage with that um like that but the thing is you can do it you can do like a double dash anywhere wherever you're facing and everything but there's a cooldown obviously i have no
so let me put the cooldowns on so the thing is i do this e i press e um i get regen with that but then i can also heal people if i press e and f it's a cleanse so if you know if a bucky ocean i just do that i can't do it yet because my cards and then and then do that okay they're dead they're dead but but if they were alive it would have worked so e e f It's a cleanse,
but it's okay.
I can't do anything right now because I don't have cards.
So, but if I have, yeah, it can counter, basically, he can, you know, if a Bucky ult's in and there's like a red thing, yeah, it's basically a cleanse.
So I have to press E and F, but I have to recharge my cards.
The cards charge passively.
But the thing is, I don't have to use it right away.
So you see the cards around me?
I get faster regen if I have it around me.
But if I do this, it cleanses people.
Yeah.
It can cleanse.
Yeah, in his...
Yeah, so...
If I press F, if I press F, it does damage.
So, and then if I press F, F...
Okay, I don't have my cards.
See, this is the annoying part.
It does anti-heal.
FF does anti-heal.
Yeah, cleanse it removes debuffs.
So any debuffs you get, I can just cleanse it with E.
Yeah.
So if I do FF...
Like, F button, and then F again?
There's anti-heal.
But it doesn't...
And then if I do...
F, E, it boops them up.
But I don't have a card.
Give me a sec.
I don't...
Oh my god.
This is the worst part.
It just...
That's why I'm saying research management.
I have to wait.
I have to wait until I have my cards.
Okay, I need two cards, basically.
F, E.
It knocks people up.
like that.
It ricochets them.
Yeah, I have to count my cards.
Don't tell the casino, guys.
Don't tell them.
There's no... It's passive.
You have to build your thing passively.
So, yeah, wait.
That's why it's like...
The thing is, you have that... He seems... You might think in theory, he seems... It's not.
It's not.
Because, like, it gets overwhelming.
Because then obviously you can't spam it because you have to... You passively build your cards.
Um...
Yeah, the cards have a cooldown.
And the thing is, you see I can have it up?
I get increased damage boost.
Um, I get, like, more damage if I have the cards out.
Yeah, E is the, E is heal.
Okay, I heal you.
And it goes, you can see it, you can see the cards bouncing back and forth.
It bounces back and forth.
So I can do a line, and I do this.
And it heals, like, back and forth, too.
Yeah.
So, there's no headshots, though.
There's no headshots.
for this.
Yeah, and then boop.
Wait.
Or is it shift?
Okay, shift.
It's shift right click.
Shift right click makes it so that you can... Yeah.
Does it cleanse blade anti-heal?
I assume it does.
I'm pretty sure it does.
Yeah, it's very... It's a lot.
And also his... His other... It's so cool.
His other... Basically, it does speed boost.
Speed boost and people can charge up faster.
So, um...
So, it's AoE, and everyone that I see, everyone that I see gets all charged, too.
And they jump, too.
They jump higher, too.
So, they all jump higher.
They have speed boost, and they build up faster.
It's too complicated going back to the jab.
As I'm saying, this is why I say if I see a close player or a rocket player playing Gambit, I know this is not for you, because even I'm so confused.
Guys, it took...
If I did not try out Gambit last night before today, I would not know what I was doing.
I had to, like, pre-try Gambit to figure out what the heck I'm doing.
Because I was so...
I was so overloaded.
It's like...
It's a lot of clicking.
It's a lot.
So, like, the thing is, I have...
Yeah, so...
He has more than four moves.
Exactly.
moves.
I can't take that.
Cool.
Thank you for the Twitch prize.
Thank you.
Yeah, he's balanced around his card.
If I have this out, I get regen technically.
I get regen.
See?
You see?
I just have... Okay, so you see this?
If I never put my card... If I don't use it, I get regen.
I also get regen from using E.
But, like, you can have your cards out so you can have...
your regen stuff yeah yeah you do that it's like shift right click so it's it's it's yeah anyway let's try out the new team ups guys okay team up tab all right what are the new ones all right so in jet light when hawk eye uses enemies hit or launch back and blade wave filled with light energy sweeps this wave passes through both it heals and boosts healing all right let's try this out i don't know what that means All right,
where is that?
Is this?
It's not that.
Oh, it was shift.
Sorry, I let him die.
Don't worry.
I don't play Hawkeye.
There we go.
I healed him.
Guys, I'm a hero.
There we go, guys.
I'm a hero.
So apparently it heals them while it does that.
All right.
So this gives him a heal, basically.
Are launched back and a bled Okay, so it boosts healing for allies while damaging Oh, and it boosts healing too And applies vulnerability Oh my god, wait, it applies vulnerability That's crazy So it makes them easier to kill So this boosts healing and also And also like Heals and then damage the other person Knocks them back and boosts vulnerability Alright,
okay, we got to see the widow Widow shit All right.
Gains her.
Explose on her Phoenix rounds and heal allies in the blast radius.
Explose on impact.
What the heck?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, stop letting them die.
Okay.
What's the cooldown though for this?
I need a note.
Oh my god, I'm a healer.
I don't think I don't think I'll know any healer that's gonna do this.
Wait, is there a cooldown?
There's no cooldown?
Wait!
Oh, but it does less damage.
Wait, she is triple!
Oh my god, wait, she could...
Okay, there's...
Okay, you cannot play her as like triple support.
You cannot play her as a secondary support.
But like, there's no cooldown.
But the only issue is that it's less damage.
Actual...
Headshots don't do more damage.
I don't think so.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
See?
It doesn't even do more healing.
Yeah, it doesn't do more healing.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, does that have AoE?
Wait a minute!
Oh, it does less healing, though.
But I can technically miss.
Game is game.
Yeah, yeah, I can technically miss and heal, but it does do less healing.
That's the thing.
You don't have to headshot, too.
I thought I thought there'd be a cooldown but there's no cooldown that's crazy that's actually crazy bro why play ultran yeah why play ultran the only issue is that it does do less damage but bro I could snipe play bro like but the thing is I can heal from so far away I can literally just perch up and be like a sniper healer like from here like I don't have to do anything and her pretty crazy.
I think her ult is like one of the strongest ults.
But like it's her ult is so strong when for people who know how to use it.
I can't heal myself.
Oh yeah, they did do.
What else did they change?
Yes, really?
What?
Okay.
This one's crazy though.
What was it?
Like bro, this is crazy.
This is insane.
Wait, there's no cooldown?
Wait a minute!
Oh wait, there is.
There is.
Okay, I was gonna be like, there's no way.
Okay, that is crazy.
That is so strong.
There is cooldowns.
Thank God for that.
I was gonna be like, freaky out if there's no cooldowns for that.
Thank God.
Okay, it's a 30 second cooldown.
That is strong.
That is very strong.
Lay's swing in a pot, dashing for it at the end, and he swooshly dashes.
Okay, I'll play this, and I won't understand what I'm doing.
I don't play play late.
How do I do this?
Oh my god!
Wow!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, gosh.
I heard that came from the zombie mode, too.
Yeah, that's...
Yeah.
That's scary.
Wow, okay.
That's a lot of damage.
Yeah, that's a lot.
That's a lot of that.
So those are all the new team up.
did hear, I did hear that they did make a couple, they buffed a lot, they buffed everything and nerfed nothing.
So, this one thing that I really liked is that you can finally put a shield in front of you.
Like, you don't have to be like, please, team, team, team, get over, team, team, get over here.
I'm getting so bad.
Team.
Also, it's a lot bigger now.
I don't know if you noticed this, But the shield grew twice as the size.
It is a lot bigger.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that is huge.
It's actually so freaking big.
Yeah.
Yeah, so they did that.
So you don't have to, you know.
Also, the push range is bigger now.
It is bigger.
Oh, it's just for yourself.
Oh, my God.
It's just for myself, too.
Wait, my shield is so much bigger than your shield.
That's right.
It's bigger.
The shield is bigger than it looks in the mirror.
It's right.
My shield is bigger than your shield.
Yeah, why?
I can just use myself shield.
Oh, my God.
Is it cold outside for you?
So this is the one thing I kept track of.
Because I was like, I can give myself a shield.
All right, whatever stuff did they change that you guys want to check out?
I was like, girl, I can think of it.
Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I realized my bunny hop isn't binding.
So, there you go.
Yeah, I need it.
Alright.
What other buffs do you guys want to check?
The double mag bubbles?
Wait, what was the thing change?
What did they change on the thing?
What did they do?
Penny heals now?
What?
What does thing do?
He's blue.
Other than being blue, chat.
He has team-wide reduction.
That?
No, that's not it.
That can't be it.
It's just one.
I don't know what this is.
His jumping applies, Varanagan nearby.
Oh, his jumping applies.
Oh, yeah, it does.
Oh, it does.
Look, he's glowing now.
Yeah.
right click on a tank all right gambit you're you're mine all right all right where is the tank spawn all right spawn in another spawn bro oh okay you're the closest i don't think i don't see any okay oh he's look at that he's pink now
Has max HP damage now?
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh, he's Urple now.
Yeah, because he...
It's a vulnerability.
So when I do the F, F key, he has like bigger vulnerability.
All right, what does Penny do?
Apparently Penny heals now.
How does she heal?
The concealed cyber...
Oh!
Immobilized Penny and allied skin and...
movement while in the... Oh, wait, what?
The web of life and destiny is fragile.
Someone has to protect it.
Are you getting healed?
Are you getting healed, ma'am?
I think he is.
I can't see... Oh, wait.
Let me...
I realize I don't have the heal thing on.
Where was that?
It was on...
Controller.
Okay, let's see.
Ally health bars.
Alright, there you go.
Oh yeah!
Wait, he's getting healed!
How many can I have up there?
Wait, does this stack?
Oh my god, it heals!
Oh, well, he can't outlive that, but oh my god, it's healing!
Like very slowly, very, very slowly.
It's not a lot, but it's getting there.
Uh, like, thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you.
Like, you know, he's getting there.
It's something, you know?
And that's movement buff, too, you know?
Like, it's something.
Look at that.
Look at he dies.
It takes him a longer time to die.
That's all that matters.
Is it her web?
I think it's just her web.
Yeah, oh, wait, no.
Oh, it's a spider next to us, too.
You're up, little one.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Oh.
Oh, I got you.
I mean, that's...
That's...
Oh, he's dead.
Oh.
okay he's dead but you know that's just something he's he died he died but you know it it let him live for five seconds it's like a band-aid yeah i mean it's like a little band-aid but you know i stopped the blood for a little you know he might have died from blood loss but i stopped it a little bit I yeah it gave over yeah yeah yeah you know it might blend through the band-aid but you know it's the thought that counts yeah band-aid made of webs it's the thought that counts guys it really is all right all right what else what else that yeah that five seconds yeah I gave a band-aid until that healer came over,
okay?
I was like, here's a band-aid for your boo-boo.
I'm gonna take you to the hospital now.
All right, what does Mr. Fantastic do?
What is this new change?
Um, like I said, they buffed everything and I couldn't keep track.
I couldn't keep track.
I don't play Mr. Fantastic, so I don't know exactly.
All right, do you guys notice anything different i don't he can shield while inflated now they buff more yeah you can use rectangle while in inflated mode what the heck does rectangle mean it's in his oh it's in his macho state okay
oh nothing happened oh go to a hundred all right how do i all right don't i got this all right don't worry i'm always at 100 all right oh no i need more come on all right oh i could do that while in macho okay i get it i get it now so i can go like big mode i can go big mode while like uh to reflect while no i just did reflect that's fly.
All right, there you go.
Don't worry, I'm almost there.
There you go.
That's right.
I'm big boy now.
What you gotta do about that?
Okay.
No, it didn't end early.
It's just because, like, I went into reflection.
I'll reflect.
Yeah, I went to reflect mode.
So when you go reflect mode, it ends in the big mode early.
Yeah.
Let me see.
So, let's see.
I'm big bow now, like that, and I can end it here.
And just do, like, the reflect.
Reflect time.
Alright.
Is there anything else?
Anything else that's new?
You guys want to check out?
We have five more minutes before we go to Time Square.
Rocky Raccoon?
Yeah, but we don't care about that.
Like, who shoots this gun at Rocket?
Like, Like, who shoots this gun as rocket?
I still...
Oh, the Magneto Bupkod.
Magneto gets everything.
What?
It's not fair.
He gets everything.
It's crazy.
Look, I can shield myself.
And I can shield the other person.
Oh, wait.
I got two bubbles now.
Let's go.
Oh, they separated the bubbles now.
Oh, I just noticed that.
Wait, oh, wait.
They separated the bubbles.
Yeah, I get my own shield.
I get my own shield.
And then I can also shield him.
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's actually great.
I love that.
Because then you feel like Magnum feels sorry.
I shielded myself.
I was like, that's a lie.
I was like, they changed that to season five.
You can't use that excuse anymore.
I know you have a shield.
You can't say you shielded yourself.
You can't say that no more.
Yeah, now you have...
You can't say sorry I wasted a bubble on myself Because you have one bubble just for other
Now you have to help me Alright Sorry I bubbled this way Yes, I bubbled the wrong person Now he just has to bubble the wrong person What's the team up like?
Oh, I showed team up but it's crazy um can we see how fast dead adam is now oh yeah you want to see how fast adam is all right but i'll show the team up again team up is strong as hell look like this is this is scary this is this is unneeded
that is so unneeded yeah that doesn't believe It is very much Unneeded for him.
He already has everything.
Most likely I won't be playing Gambit first.
I think Ninja... Oh yeah.
I'll be on a team with Ninja, Tim, Las, Craigie, and J3.
Most likely I think Ninja will be playing Gambit first.
Everything.
Most likely.
But I'll play Gambit second.
But even then he's... I don't know.
Gambit is so scary.
Gambit...
is a lot he really is he's a lot of information yeah cuz I mean I usually let them play it first because you know I can I like you know I'm not in a rush to I'm not like I'm not in a rush to play gambit you know but like I I don't really care uh oh you don't have the recolor but I have this one i like the default more but i think it's just preference because i love the default design of gambit also i think we're supposed to are you supposed to go to town time square now okay no uh all right uh no not yet okay i just want to be sure we're not if we're supposed to go to time square uh what else oh yeah someone wants to check out the hulk bus what did they do for
The cleanse is crazy.
Cleanse is always crazy.
We didn't show the valve pass already, but I can look at it after Times Square.
What did they do to Hulk?
His clap reduces his shield?
That.
What the fuck is...
Don't think they didn't make him blue.
What does it do?
That.
By the way, you can't clap three times.
I just took the cooldown off.
All right.
There we go.
Is that?
Like I said, I don't know.
I don't play Hulk, so I don't know what they do differently.
I don't know.
Is he blue, though?
Unfortunately, he is not blue, guys.
I'm sorry.
I know you would love if he was blue, but unfortunately, he is not blue.
clap.
Oh, they lower the cooldown?
Okay.
Bumpa and then bubble.
Clap!
There we go.
I did it.
That's all you get on hug.
That's it.
That's all you get.
Oh, okay, alright.
It's time for time square, I believe.
I believe it's time square time.
Alright.
I just go in.
Should everybody else be here now?
Oh, hey, Super is here.
Alright.
See, we all follow the...
We all follow the briefing.
There's time here.
This is what I was saying!
It actually has Disney Plus ads.
Like...
That's what I'm saying.
It's Disney Plus ads right here.
Hi, neighbor.
Well, hello there.
This is where you get role-playing now.
Real-time squaring.
All right.
Yeah, so there's like a bunch of ads.
Look, oh my god.
See, he's a menace.
I told you.
He's a goddamn menace.
And then there he is over here.
And then there's like, there's a bunch of ads.
It's just ads.
It's just, it's Kingpin.
There's the test kitchen.
There's like, oh look, there's, there's like, you can eat what your favorite, oh my god, it's like those people were really lonely and they eat what was plushy.
That's, that's us.
There's Van Dunes, Coffee Bean, the tomb of Dracula.
There's ice cream, guys.
Wait, how far can I go?
Wait, there's so much.
There's Wakanda.
There's Marvel Unlimited.
Hello, sir.
Oh, my God.
Marvel .com Unlimited.
It's an ad within an ad.
Some healing would be nice.
Yeah, so they have it this way.
Hub menu.
Oh, there's everybody else.
How do I...
Is there no voice chat?
Am I even in the voice chat?
lobby audio push to talk okay uh what is my push to oh no voice changer it is okay i don't know if there is i don't think you can it's just our normal rp it's like slash rp yeah i think 100 person voice chat would be a bit too much yeah so there's there's wilson there's more kingpin right there universal ninja store why does ninja get his own store
It's not big!
He gets his own store, too?
Like...
He gets early access and his own store?
That's not big.
I think it's not Ninja Ninja.
I think this is so funny.
That it gives me Disney Plus ads.
I guess.
Have you guys subscribed to Disney Plus yet?
Chat?
It actually is like New York City, though.
It feels like New York City.
But it's trying to get us out of Doom Q.
Like, they're like, get out of Doom Q.
When people role play here.
They're making us role play here now.
I like how there's like, there's like little crossing thing.
Yeah, it's a product placement.
Just like the real...
Wait, there's subway.
Oh, wait, no, never mind.
I was going to...
What?
There's a hot topic.
You get it.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
No way.
Why is hot topic a bar?
That's just hot topic.
Hey.
Oh, my God.
It's a fancy as hot topic, guys.
So aren't you hot?
Topic.
What is he doing?
He crushed the vampire.
Now he's New York towards a brighter.
But, no, no, no.
Oh my god, he wants.
No, he can't win.
Dad wants to go to Hot Topic.
He really does.
That's crazy.
I didn't realize it would be Hot Topic here.
There's no bookstore.
Alright, come on.
No, no.
Come on.
No.
Alright, he wins.
Give me a sec.
I gotta give him food.
He wins.
I'll look at the hot topic.
I gave him a little treat.
I want to enjoy hot topic.
It works every time.
It's because I'm sponsored, okay?
I need him to be because I'm trying to look through the things.
Pim Test Kitchen.
I think it's funny that oh accidentally added him bonjour bonjour mon ami that's crazy i like how everything is like you know like um oh my god there's the avengers gift store like just tony stark doesn't need more money he technically he doesn't need more oh my god there's pure capitalism he of course he's merchandising the avengers like He made,
he's merchandising the adventures.
Yes, he does.
He wants a little bit more money for Tony Stark.
You think Stark now or come?
Yeah, he sold out, bro.
He's sold.
I still can't believe there's Hot Topic.
Bro, like, everything else is a parody.
And then there's goddamn Hot Topic.
Like, where did that go from?
It's just literally on topic.
I mean, it is time square.
I do admit, it is time square.
You're like, Emma took everything from the divorce.
She sure did.
That's crazy.
That's actually hilarious.
I was not expecting.
I was not expecting it.
But yes, there's going to be a lot of RP here.
Oh my god, that's...
have the i was gonna say hello everyone this time oh look there's the delivery man he's here to deliver look at that he's gonna take your job soon guys he's here take your job how much until the game starts i think we have at least 10 more minutes 10 more minutes oh yeah um by the way okay watch the we'll have the ads playing up here um but i was i was told to show to show you as the roadmap for the new season um let me see if i could find it roadmap for the new season i saved the png of it let's see oh my god it's a big picture it's a big image so this is like what to expect for season five poop so there is obviously we got the gambit stuff already we got gambit the new costume which is what we had which was what's going to released in November 14th and then there's also the new map here the new accessories and then November 21st we get magic and doctor strange because I'm so looking forward to 28 because you get business Jeff and business Jeff is gonna be for free uh and there's also
a new map and new game mode so 18 versus 18 and the grand garden which is I believe where he got married where Rogan uh Gambit got married and then the Luna snow and siloque uh uh rivals the anniversary skin i love i love business jeff business jeff is gonna be a free skin too yeah business jeff is my favorite one he's out here doing business i want that yummy yummy tax form skin and then yeah so obvious season 5.5 will be rogue so looking forward to 5.5 it's crazy that you know we get a new character every month i think that that's insane that that's just insane um like pro like insane like um updates and stuff no vc because what if because i don't want to hear a hundred people in vc that's a good point you know if there was a hundred people in there that's that's crazy that would be crazy Yeah,
you see, you can literally hear the video.
You can hear the trailer.
Certified fresh rotten tomato.
I'm just gonna watch this.
I will go insane.
I'm gonna look up.
How can I look up?
I don't understand.
If you're streaming on...
let's run does it kill bitrate
my um cooked and you do not oh does it does it kill bitrate and we look up hi neighbor i'm counting on you man a shield that's okay we're on twitch yeah 100 people vc would actually like it'll be very immersive i will agree it will be incredibly immersive if we get a hundred people oh that's cool we can cue oh we can cue up our stuff here oh i like that i like that a lot uh but yeah gambit is joining um season five so make sure to click on the link in the panel or pin in the chat to download marvel rivals right now and play for free it does help out the channel a lot do shout again to the devs for uh sponsoring being like the um being the v-tuber representative for the early access it's it's a huge honor so i really appreciate see look at that everyone has cards look at that go do your thing if 100 people start talking like i think the sound system would break honestly oh yeah that's the king guide i like they gave tim the queen guide and they gave me the king i'm gonna be so
overwhelmed this what if they did proximity chat there's gonna be a lot of gamers then for sure it would be very funny i wonder like it would be meeting a lot of people too
how are the ps4 getting into this mode i don't be the same as any other mode wouldn't it be Let's go.
Let's go get out of the thing.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
It's another new ad.
What's, what, what is this?
What show is this now?
Chills down your spines.
Are this Agatha?
Wait, would I get DMCA's?
Oh, werewolf fight.
Oh, no, we saw this.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I'm thinking like, if I, if I am in time square, YouTube with, like, the audio clips of this?
With the audio clips of this?
Give me, like, uh, Disney shall take your monetization.
That'd be pretty funny.
I want to test that out.
I'm going to test that out in season 5.
I'll go to Times Square and I start just watching the screen and see if it hits me.
I'll do that on YouTube.
I think it'd be pretty funny.
Yeah.
You want my Bad revenue, mouse.
Taking one for the team exactly.
Oh, wait.
Are we supposed to?
How did...
Wait, how did Jimbo Limbo get here?
Wait.
Wait, you're not part of the early access.
How did you get in?
How did...
Wait a minute, Jimbo Limbo?
You're not on the list.
Who's Jimbo?
How did he get in here?
I know Jimbo, he's like from EU.
He's an EU player.
But he's not on the list, though.
I thought this was...
No, it's not a dev.
It's just a regular guy.
No, he's not a dev.
He's like...
He's a regular guy from EU.
How did you get in here?
He's Jimbo.
He's just...
He came in through the back door.
One of these is not like the other.
Truly isn't.
He's like, I know, don't keep it.
Don't worry.
Like, she's waiting for me inside the club.
Yeah, he has a plus one to the wedding.
You're right.
I mean, look up what we have to do here.
Uh...
I'll make sure.
Alright.
That's really it.
There's more Easter eggs?
They were like, look at the Easter eggs.
I think I found all the Easter eggs.
Like, Hot Topic.
I think that's all.
Hot Topic was the Easter egg.
I mean, there's stuff here.
Energy fair today.
There's, like, stuff outside the border, too.
Which I noticed.
No, you can't go into any of the buildings, unfortunately.
I think that would break the game if you do.
This is a...
What if Hot Topping was a bar?
That's good.
Wait, there's Box Lunch, too.
Isn't that, like, a bag brand?
Or is that Lunch Box?
I don't remember.
No, that's something else.
I was thinking about something else.
Queen in Black Cube Rule Ring.
What if Hot Topic was blue, guys?
Just...
Yeah, oh yeah.
I was thinking about...
Yeah, I was thinking about different red.
Guys, what if Hot Topic was blue?
That would be wild.
Imagine...
I would...
I hope in April 4th, they just turned all the characters blue.
Today's special Anna's pork pie.
Ooh, that looks good.
Pizza hot and tasty.
Tastes like chrome.
Ooh, nice.
NYTTD, major crime unit.
I trust the kingpin.
Look at him.
Oh, wait.
You can fly all the way there?
What?
Oh, that's cool.
Wait, you can play B-Ball.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's just a Kong shoe.
Okay, someone.
Wait, I can play...
The baller is back, guys.
I can play B-ball.
That's cool.
I didn't realize there was a basketball court.
We're balling now.
That's cool.
I like that.
I like that you can play B- You can just go and play B-ball.
I think we have, like, our beachy modes, too.
We're the ball.
You gotta make your ball.
It's Mag vs.
Mag D-Baltap.
Port of the basket.
Oh, there's like plushies here, too.
Wait, I noticed that.
There's like plushies here as well.
I'm always nervous.
I'm going to be nervous for the group.
I'm always nervous in the big matches.
Because I know I, like, played with them before.
Like, five people.
Five is more than two.
That's a lot.
Rocket is the bot.
I'm going to be super nervous.
It's also, it's like, you know, Tim and Ninja.
And them, they're like, you know, they've been streaming for so long.
No, it's me.
Tim, Ninja, Laz, Craigie, and J3.
That's the group.
What the heck?
Are they going to play basketball now?
Go play basketball.
Oh, they're all waiting for all charges.
Oh my god, wait, you're right!
Someone pick me up.
Come on, guys.
We gotta do a walk in the...
Hulk thing in the...
Guys, come on.
I don't want...
You guys can imply what I'm talking about.
Hold me like a basketball.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Hold me like a basketball, guys.
Oh, my God.
Do I have to spell it out for all of you?
Slam dunk me.
I have to spell it out.
I'll have to go in.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, okay.
He got it.
Wait, how do I, how do I get in?
Wait, why can't I get on?
Why can't I get?
No!
Oh, wait, there we go.
How do I get on?
Why can't I get on?
I can't team up!
No!
What's the point?
Alright, guys, I have to get into the VC real quick.
Can't even team up.
I need to add my...
What's the point?
How do I be ball?
How can I be far?
All right, let me set up the overlay, guys.
Give me a sec.
All right, whips, get it set up.
Whips, set it up.
Whips, blow this house up.
Oh, my God.
All right.
That's a sound guide.
So, wait, who's healing?
Who's healing?
Message me on this way.
Oh, I'm supporting you.
i was gonna say y'all get hello hello yo yo um i can try i mean i i'm done i would love to try the new cnd as well so i can like gambit all right let's see let me fix this i mean bro honestly we could trip support we gave it to wait we get technically we can triple support with widow oh yeah it's all so true your reels are good all right all right let's see okay let me let me real quick uh okay marvel ravages preview must be nice dude uh where the heck is it okay it's always hard to find i have so many servers so i have to find the exact server for this because i have to use my discord over there we should quintuple support one tank i'm gonna run the the healing widow yeah no we need to do that this is mine am i team b voice phoenix team b voice chat there you go again i wonder if you do damage boost with mantis on a healing widow does she technically heal more and damage more like that's a great question yeah then we can run four supports we test it right quick yeah hang on dokey
what's your naming game i'll hide you real quick oh it's just dokey bait oh my gosh no way big that's insane i can't believe it i know i can't believe no one else took that name it's so easy it's crazy uh who's not in here that's in this uh it's craggy's here jay team lasses no lasses here uh am i trolling i haven't invited i haven't invited jokie it would be in it's me it's me okay do we want to try practicing just quick yeah yeah yeah super fast super fast okay i will go mantis
someone go um widow someone go phoenix i will exist on phoenix one's an x-man all right okay someone go to okay uh inspire here all right there you go you're inspired no it doesn't oh is it just it's just no norma yeah try to join his party you'll have to join website but maybe it does hold on hold on and there you go i went to the sea I love this background music.
Are you guys going to shoot?
I did.
Hold on.
Wait, just me up.
Just me up real quick.
Just me up.
What are you guys doing, bro?
You're not coming in here with me?
Oh, no.
I don't think so.
Yeah, it looks like the same.
Wait, so why did you not do joint viewership?
Well, here, do do damage.
Oh, we are.
Let me see.
Let me see how much damage boosts, doesn't it?
Okay.
Is it like strong?
No, you still have to hit him four times.
It's four times with or without.
Oh, so like, oh, so he doesn't do anything.
it does nothing trash it's awful who do we who are we adding in i don't know i'm in the lobby i think i'm on 119 ping i will say that to me invite me to me i'm not gonna invite everyone else right you're not on my friend's list i gotta wait i think i added you i added last i added you yep i accepted you busted the myth so is there is there a new map here right now or is it just the it's a time square thing is the new map right now it's just a time square that's really it i think like later they said like on the road map they're releasing a new map later gotcha i think it was like mid-season for five got you swapped to the swap to the right team brother oh are we playing gambit look at our pings bro oh wait why are we playing eu why are we at i don't know bro oh yeah okay now i know why we're in frankfurt now yeah there are more you better drop a million there are more any players in this lobby than there are europeans so talk to any servers immediately so swap um east coast servers
right no we should do west coast servers at that point don't worry i want i want necros on 150 yeah craig yeah craig you could carry she's craig you live right next to frankfurt or something man goodness gracious that ping you got i believe in craig you on 150 ping wait he stopped it to northern virginia there we go not bad not bad there we go we almost have the same ping now yeah i know that's that's what being in west coast is like yeah that's that's crazy that's how big na is it's massive it's massive yo hey come on i've been saying i've been saying i mean i'm gonna be be completely honest with you guys it it has officially died these last two months officially a low tamper fade meme it lasted like what five years chat four years what's that meme no oh my god well you see there's this in bedrock if i have to explain it um we're down bad well you see there's this map with a bunch of conclusions on it to yeah i call it a jump to conclusions matt and then oh man no one gets the
opposite i don't think any of you got that reference wow oh my god am i that old now oh my god it's okay timmy all right let's see we're adjusting this right now okay tim down craigley slightly done i'm 35 bro i'm actually like when people say pushing 40 by the way like i'm actually pushing it tim and craigie little bit craiggy down again craig is like 82.
all right craig is down a little bit sound guy let me know when everything is okay
all right wait who's playing gambit on our team i've been banned for a year and i've never even been in his stream before by the way is that crazy by the way that's happened a lot like there are a lot of streams i'll randomly tune into and it's like you're banned i'm like oh What?
I've never been here.
Maybe you're on the list.
You're on like this like bad list.
Bro got preemptively banned, bro.
Dude, he banned me.
He unbanned me.
Let's go.
Oh, email address is banned now.
Oh, you had to get a run, man.
All right.
See you.
All right, sound guy.
I lowered Craigie.
I lowered Tim.
Let me know if everything's good.
Craigie?
I think so, bro.
You could have a rare Tim to tap man.
Bucky angle.
Oh.
Wait, we have to ban ninja now?
I mean, if somebody wants to play DP, I thought you were still.
Listen, if no one wants to play the new character, I'll try Gambit.
Oh, yeah, brother.
Doki can go Gambit.
Yeah, I could do Gambit.
And I'll start Invisible Woman.
Oh, you see your giant ass shield now?
Yes, she has revealed she's putting it on her.
It's so good.
I'm praying that I get ulted.
I'm praying someone ulted me.
Magneto.
Come here, Mag.
Wait, wait, Jay.
Do you want to do Moon Knight Blade first or Phoenix and Widow first?
Ooh, whatever you want, my friend.
I saw the, what do you call it, the Blade.
He looks crazy.
I don't have a tank team up, right?
It's unlimited range, you know that, right?
No, it's just McNeil that has it.
Yeah, Magnus.
Gambit.
All right, last you go Magnus, obviously.
Are you sure you didn't want to go Magnus first?
No, you can.
Make way for the King of Tees.
What would you like to play, sir?
You want to do it?
Let's get it.
Hulk smash!
You're paid later, Moon Knight.
Was that the real Hulk?
Oh, it's up to you.
Is that the Hulk in our team right now?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you're too nice, bro.
You pop off on Blade.
Craig, did you actually play Blade?
No.
Oh, he'll be good.
We're learning.
It's okay.
We're learning today.
If Necros is on Spider-Man, I am leaving the ad.
There's no way.
Look at her come.
What is he going to grab?
Me!
I will.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
He's going to grab me.
me but after that who is he gonna grab with the thing changes that is gonna grab you oh yeah i have to cleanse myself yeah grab me if i cleanse myself people are gassing up the thing swap in his suit it's so good i think the thing and the captain america are the two biggest changes for tank captain america is the same they buff everything and nerfed nothing i'm scared They're telling me he's on Spider-Man.
All right, guys.
All right, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'll cleanse you.
Play his can.
Nah, you got this.
You got this.
You're so healthy.
Oh, it's great.
Oh, my God.
You guys are already making so much damage.
I'm a draggy.
You went so deep, bro.
Phoenix One is on top.
I'm dead.
Oh, we're dead.
Phoenix up top, by the way.
Shooting for free.
Yeah, he's just having high ground for free.
This isn't good.
We're sweating.
They're trying to guard.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I have cards.
I'll go widow.
They run a trip now.
They are solo tank, though.
With the widow, it's kind of a great idea.
Yeah, I think they have a lot of subpoenas.
We need that triple sub.
I could go.
I can swap.
I will swap.
Yeah.
I can go high ground real quick.
Is there a character I should go?
Maybe Cloak?
I don't even know.
Got you.
I got you.
Oh, God.
I think this is good for now.
This is rough.
I'm trying to heal you.
No, one shot comes.
She's one.
She's actually nice.
I have no more cards right now.
No, bro.
We gotta get this Phoenix, bro.
Someone's got it.
She's out.
She's going to get healed again.
Can't really use my cards for your offense.
If you...
Oh, bye.
Watch out!
I couldn't heal you.
He didn't get me.
Wait, they could die here.
They could die here!
That is nice!
I got you.
Thank you, thank you.
Got their only tank?
I'm helping you.
That was awesome.
All I had to do was put my shield up.
I didn't.
Why?
That's very easy.
I have a lot here.
I feel like we should use Invis first, and then I can build it all together.
get it for us yeah i have it i gotta we gotta get another point
holy schmoly all right let's go i believe i'm walking i believe i believe
oh oh my god yeah that's unfortunate okay i'm gonna up here Nice one, Dad.
Let's go!
Gambit.
We give it.
I got it.
I made it to win it.
I'm gonna end this woman.
Use this, use this bell.
Dad, yo, this Phoenix Pro, he's a demon, bro.
Oh my god.
Bro, I'm close.
I got you.
Oh, we got sniped.
Oh, there's a sniper.
Are you guys getting it?
I can't tell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna run it.
They're not using portal.
They're not making portal.
We're fine.
Push mag back.
Yeah, they're not touching my eyes.
There's a Spider-Man bug.
Love you guys, watch out.
Spider-Man half, Spider-Man half, I love you guys.
Back you?
Yo, go kid him, Frankie.
Okay, Gambino is crazy.
We just ran in.
Spider-Man behind me.
Tucker's out.
I'm here.
No problem.
I'm gonna ult him here, bro.
I'm literally just getting some space a little.
I'm trying to...
Look at him back here.
All right, I got your heels.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He's playing B-B-B-B-B.
Nice block.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
The perfect Spider-Man ult right here.
Okay, I can't cleanse it.
I don't have the cards.
That's fine.
If we don't die, really.
He has it.
I got older.
Well, that needs to die.
I don't have the cards.
Take care.
Oh, poof.
Ooh, still got an edge.
Yes.
Oh.
There you go.
How long?
We have like so many people on us back here.
I'm on my way back.
Everyone died.
Everyone died this way.
I am close to up.
You mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
I'm dead bro, that's all I know.
You're so healthy!
I'm so, I've never been healthier.
Yeah, yeah, it's okay.
I saved the other support.
I don't know about you though.
Holy moly.
Oh my god, you have one HP.
I'm opening up this pit, bro.
But okay, you guys got to use ult so I can use my ult to build your ult
All right Do you see me Fine, we're fine.
We're still in the woods.
He's only my left.
We're still in the middle.
Oh, oh I'll use my ult too
There you go.
I cleansed us.
I don't know if I don't know if it cleansed anything but I cleansed us Akros on me half Yep, he's half he's half.
I'm on in this woman I'm gonna get out of here.
I don't even know.
Wait, there's a Phoenix army.
I'm dead.
I'm never more proud of my whole life.
I got you?
Oh my god.
Massive.
I'm Bruce.
I'm a Bruce man.
You are so good.
You're so good.
Don't hit me as Bruce.
You're so healthy.
Sorry for cussing.
That was such a good.
That was such a good block.
Oh my gosh.
Bro, that John Assouce shield saved your ass.
stayed out one of flats okay what happened where oh there
block my james behind my mind okay i got you pretty sure he's gonna have more here soon there's a phoenix behind us phoenix one nice oh i got hit by the i had nothing you might be still winnable still winnable yeah yeah you're up you're even right now the widow the widow's almost dead oh yeah i lost it james all right i can see i'll see a cart push i'm trying to get craggy i'm good for now thank you oh help him out help him out when my cards are i don't know the hill anything but i'm throwing my cards out
this guy's a natural on the hulk i played another character like this one so i played these games before nice 1v1 timmy thanks guys i know what's going on but i believe
oh my god wait there's a spider-man here
yeah look
We'll go with him.
He's gonna be behind us any second.
Here.
I might need help though.
I know you need help.
Oh, no!
Oh, bummer.
I'm holding on point.
On point.
You have hold.
Okay, I'm coming back a little.
Yeah.
I don't got bubble time.
I'm good.
Oh, dude.
He won for me still.
I'm coming back.
Live.
Oh, run, Craigie.
I'm trying to live.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
Just got you.
But where?
We all...
We go in.
there you go okay he's alting too he's alting too i don't know now is it not we got him we got him we got him we got him guys i'm pushing it on mag yeah yeah i'm here i'm on mag i'm with you oh yeah oh yeah beat him up beat him up beat him up beat him up he's out he's out he's out he's out he's out oh it's fine it's fine we're still healthy i can't even get my i don't have My home boys.
We got them.
We got this.
We got this way.
I have cards in.
Oh my god.
I'm just standing on it.
What a bowl.
Yeah I'm here.
So I'm here.
I'm going for him.
I'm going for bruce.
Oh snap.
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
Everybody I got a shot in the air.
I can't do anything.
I'm healing.
Here.
We have infants all too.
I'm gonna have off the point a little bit.
bit then oh my god they're coming over coming over with my and it will have 20 olds after
okay nine two oh
just kill that's kill that's a point kill that's a point we win that
Let's go!
Somebody get the door!
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Oh my goodness, dude.
Yo, don't keep great heels on Gambit there, bro.
That was absolutely fine.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh, like, hurt.
His E is crazy because we're all together.
So it does like so much healing too.
That's fine, dude.
Do you want to do...
Nice job.
If there's a woman.
Hey, yo, you did it too.
You did get two.
Thanks, dude.
to do the you want to do the stuff tim you remember when i was all like disappear remember that yeah where's the where's black widow at let's see last up tim up okay last uh i'll do the black widow tim boys oh i got the new skin too with her so we're good all right sound guy i got tim and last up jay can come down a little the texas um you know spongebob all right let me know if it's you've seen that dude i have seen that okay bro do you remember when they're running away and then sandy just whips her little rope and then pulls patrick and then a nuclear bomb goes off that's how i feel with necros on the other team or i'm just i'm just getting yoink off the map it's gonna happen a thousand times don't let it happen don't worry you see in the cave he can't link you out they're probably gonna funnel through the right and also my web ski i'm gonna really try to play these webs aggressively because they heal now oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yo i'm not gonna do anything but heal so good luck guys yo hawk stud there's a guy about me behind us oh there's just so many healers i got you i got you oh you've never been healed more in your life jay i sent him away he's one he's one never had better He'll never have better heels.
They've never had better heels.
Oh my god.
Oh, but Tim's dying.
Tim's dying Oh, yeah, you're out though.
You're out though.
Don't worry about it.
All right.
What are your healers back?
Your healers back He's fine.
He's fine.
There you go.
Nice.
That's it.
Assam two one.
Hit him.
There you go.
Hulk one.
Nice.
Hulk low.
Whoa, get away from me.
Oh, there's a game of mine is one.
Yeah, there's a daredevil behind us.
Get away from us.
How is he hitting it?
He can't see.
He's blind.
That's not supposed to work like that.
It's just like cold case files.
Yeah, I got the resume.
I got you.
Are they just scared?
Are they just playing around your mind?
Oh my god, great bubble.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
I'm not using that.
Oh, he got nothing.
He got nothing.
He went.
Mealing.
Oh my god.
He got you.
I'm breaking it.
Nice, nice.
Oh, guys.
I might need help, though.
There's a daredevil on me.
Yeah, I'm on him.
I'm on him with you.
him yeah i'm here i got you ninja oh my god i got you i got you how do you like that dude oh he's one he's one he's dead he's dead he can't hurt you no more oh my god oh no ninja oh no oh you're dead for sure
yeah i don't know okay i'm gonna hold after this i mean our old ass that whole time we didn't get any limbs i'm gonna use it okay let's go venom Oh, you guys are anti-aligned.
Oh my god.
I don't know what's going on, honestly.
Why?
There's so many us.
Yeah, some default asses.
Bro, we use every LU possible.
I got you.
I have a venom on me, you guys?
Magneto's behind.
Blacks is up here.
Guys, guys, you're a liar.
Me too!
I got you.
Oh, I got you.
Rare penny.
Oh, like clean on the penny.
I don't know how weird, guys.
You can put your, you can put your nest in the smoke.
This is way harder for them to see.
That's what I've been, I've been throwing one, my shift in this one.
Yeah, it was impossible to see him in here.
Maybe one.
Oh, yeah, nice.
Oh my gosh, Cracky, you're a problem.
You're him, dude.
Venom, Venom, Venom, our healer.
Venom, our healer.
Wait, what?
Which healer?
There's, there's so many.
What are you healing?
from the clutches i'm chilling i'm chilling okay oh my god i got three taps i'm sorry for cussing oh my gosh bro okay no we have zero healers there's zero healers we don't know we have win-win here i'm healing i'm just running around hopefully my webs help hey i can just do this If we live,
I have no idea what's happening.
Oh, Tim, I'm gonna die.
It's okay.
We have red.
Tim, you stay in my LOS.
I got you healed forever.
I don't know where you're going.
Stay right there.
I got you.
I'm healing you.
Okay.
Oh, no, I didn't see the...
Oh, man.
Oh, no.
I think I'm healing you, Lazarus.
Okay, I'm dead.
We need that heal.
I mean, I'm healing you, Dad, bro.
I'm healing.
I'm getting on the point.
We can recontest.
I'm doing it.
I'm going to get on the point.
We're here.
I stalled.
I'm touching.
I'm on.
I'm here.
Nice, nice, nice.
Hey, your healer's here.
You guys are good.
Oh, that's a good old.
Oh, that's a really good old.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
I guess not.
Oh, damn.
I'm healing.
Stay right there.
Shit.
Oh, my God.
Help.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
Crazy.
That was wild.
That was it.
Fucking crazy fight.
Ty, you want to stay on Rocket still?
Ah, no, no, no, no.
It's fine, it's fine.
You want to swap?
I'll do Luna.
Yeah, he's off a spot, or you're safe now.
I'm safe.
I'm okay.
He can't hurt you no more.
I'm okay, I'm okay, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Got you?
I'm good.
I feel better.
Venom?
Yeah, we heal each other.
Oh, before you.
Get out.
Big heals.
Got you have quick heals.
Go in.
Be aggressive.
Yeah, go.
Push in.
Yeah, we have so many heals.
We could go up.
Coming over?
Knocker the one left side.
Better on us again.
Better on your healers.
Oh, I'm backing up.
I'm backing up.
Oh, I can see there's so many back lives.
There's three people back live.
We got way too aggro, boys.
We got way too aggro.
Oh.
We're gonna use their ult and then after all our ults I can use the gambit All right, I'm gonna play Adam bro.
I'm gonna go Adam Wait, what were you using first?
Oh, there's a big one up and his woman and I'm not really under me and I wasn't really that of a boss right?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're fine.
We're still healthy We're no longer healthy I can touch Who's touching who's touching?
I messed up.
And your aunt healed.
It's okay, but at least we got healed, guys.
At least we got healed.
I'm coming back the more.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you are still alive.
Good health, good health.
I cannot heal anymore.
I'm ulcing them.
Oh my god.
All right, we gotta push up though.
I'm a blade blade there.
Thank you.
Who know what?
All right.
Nice and nice.
We pushed up.
We got blood.
I bet him on me alone.
Where are you?
I think she went out last.
I lost her.
Oh, that does no damage when he's blocking.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ulting this for us.
So you guys can do that.
All right.
We want to push it.
One blade one blade one blade one blade one blade.
One blade dead blade.
She was really weak.
weak i'm playing for one two one two one two one two one two one two one oh nice tim oh body
you're so healthy i'm dead already no oh my god we're not longer healthy wait wait oh wait did We just die.
Just die.
We'll have time.
I do have rest for next fight.
And they just wasted three ults.
So we got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe I believe.
If we wipe or die, I'll work for Fatty, bro.
Your ult can actually make or break kind of thing here.
And they'll never expect it.
Mags left alone.
They have Adam now, by the way.
Oh, they got me.
That was good.
I don't got you anymore.
I'm dead, bro.
I'm literally just dead.
We got to push up, though, seriously.
I can't really get out.
Yeah, yeah, we got to push up.
I'm on point, though.
Yeah, I'm down.
I'm still on point.
I can start for a little bit.
Got Gambit?
Smile's going to be sick, but...
Oh!
Adam, we're like a...
How do you do this?
That's good.
We wanted to make it long, you know?
We want to showcase everything.
True.
including which side you're on one match is taking 30 minutes this is going to go back to his woman what do you think she's not great for healing she's got great healing uh let's see i did i mean i did 10 000 healing that round just half the round really you might have i got 40k healing so far that's insane i did by the way i did 6500 healing on penny there oh what that's It's kind of insane.
I mean.
I have no healing.
Tim, one more thing.
I got to pick it up.
Up to you, Jay.
What do you want to do?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Um, well, those got changed.
Uh, only other one is Hawkeye, but they changed his dagger.
Mr. Fantastic.
Mr. Fantastic got buffed.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I'll do the Hawkeye then.
Ooh, I don't, I don't play that guy.
No, no, no.
I played like a couple of minutes off him.
Uh, he's got Hawkeye in there.
Who's the Hawkeye?
Who is he teamed up with?
I mean, this guy got changed.
Uh, the Hawkeye team up?
Oh yeah, it's with Cleo, right?
He got changed?
He lost his, uh, team up, so they gave him 300 health, two extra pellets, and a shotgun, and he has, uh, more damage from range.
They just fall off.
More HP.
That's good.
I don't think they gave, they gave, like, a lot of support, more HP, too.
They're like, less squishy now.
Makes it boys great again.
Oh, they're doing it now.
They have Captain America.
Oh, no.
Captain America didn't even get buffed.
Oh, they got fake.
Oh, my God.
The shotgun.
I'm on Gambit.
Oh, my God.
I'm feeding.
Yeah, you are so low.
Oh, okay.
You're so weapon two, weapon two, weapon two.
How'd you go with the heels?
We should go.
Blade low.
I'm got I got out of that.
I couldn't dismiss bro.
He got that so fast.
Yeah, I know we were all Oh my god, they went strange.
Yeah, help me out.
I'm using my regen right now Lay it on us laid off.
Yep.
Oh, I'm waiting.
Oh, no, I couldn't No, I just got out.
No, 40% that's good though That's true.
That's true.
Bro, I was just doing the angle on the way out here.
I think maybe bro i'm gonna go rock and get some petty angle i think the res is huge you know i think the webs can heal i think that's it we gotta go full heal job make way for the king of t's i think it's the petty angle boys i agree no wait craiggy try it try the shotgun bro okay i'll try the shotgun uh what else got changed why'd you say it like that bro you you shred kills off instantly from that Let's got buffed for damage.
Yeah, it does so much healing, Chad.
It's actually crazy.
The fact that I got 40k healing already.
I just, I don't know if you're not, I'm just curious.
The storm gives more damage.
And, like, I haven't, I haven't done, like, any, I haven't used my, I should use my damage and deep buff more.
But, like, we take so much damage, yeah.
And Wolverine got buffed.
We take so much damage that I don't have a chance to do.
You guys want me to set up on point, by the way, I'm assuming.
I don't have a chance to do, like, um, we don't even want him to get close.
or no i don't know i'm thinking we can i can use the smoke okay you could put a resume you can up here too ninja if you need i i like i like this one because i can i can come back to it and should grab the shield what is this turret bro go shotgun wait i don't know a pussy oh no boys we can do this this is where we hold them we got a rare mr fantastic out of j3 bro i don't think i've ever seen this bro yeah i'm telling you this is everything.
Let's go, bro.
Yeah, if we lose, we'd be like, um, J3 was on Mr. Fantastic.
Like we weren't trying.
Oh, a thing won.
Are you okay?
I already somehow killed my thing.
I'm at 41%.
I'm not close to all.
Someone's liking Captain America.
It's one.
Captain one.
Oh, no.
I don't got myself, though.
And Craigie's back.
I'll TP.
No, okay.
Jay, I got you, Jay.
I got you big heals.
Yeah, we still have TP.
I got a TP coming in, boys.
Get up, get up, point, get up, point.
I'm going to die.
I'm dead.
We have TP coming.
You're an ult.
Nice.
Kill Gambit and the other healer.
Swap it up thing.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
I'm getting on my phone.
Don't keep talking go crazier.
It's five.
I'm almost done.
I'm almost
done.
Okay.
Ty, I got how you got?
How are you?
She got you?
Got you got two.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh,
yeah, I've been punished all guys.
Oh, crap.
We want a million dollars.
We just want a million dollars.
Good shit, guys.
Let's go.
We can just end stream early at this point.
We saw everything.
Everyone played really well there, bro.
My rocket went in.
Bro, dude.
So, Super comes in.
Captain America.
I get him one shot as Captain America.
I get him one shot.
He runs away, but he gets the beacon after someone gets Rez, right?
Someone gets Rez.
I'm pretty sure Craigie got Rez.
I chase him down.
I kill him.
And then I'm getting pushed.
And then I'm pretty sure.
that someone died to the mines that were left over of my mines wait really yeah i'm gonna double kill instantly bro insanity yo does you know i have a question that i actually didn't look at does your web heal oh i don't know respawn beacon i don't know we can check this i don't know actually i'm gonna check that out yeah wait what are we doing now are we just going again i mean i'm down to do one yeah i think we do it again until i think until like 10 15 minutes or something and then we do like that the blind date thing that might not be able to happen if this is a long one but i'm in all right who's doing gambit now i'm i gotta just yeah it's not me i'll go wait are you scared of gambit wait why are you scared it's fun man yeah why are you scared jay can you do it on the offense and can i take him on defense or whatever vice versa like whichever this one is date where we have to spin the wheel we have to spin the wheel and then like get like a random character it's called like wait
wait it's like blind date door quick oh cranky's about to do some attack with wolf bro okay they like buff loki too right i don't remember what they did to him it's him the tab man on what chad you got like actually you've never seen this before i can change
Craigie, please clip one of them, bro, please.
Guys, what did it change for Loki?
No, there it is.
Oh, it's just his HP.
Yeah, I'll see if I can do it.
Yeah, fuck that.
How is Gambit's heals?
Does he, like, have a lot of heals?
Yeah, no, he does a lot.
If you do, like, if you use E, he does so much heals.
Oh, God.
And do my cards just recharge, right?
Yeah, yeah, it's like a passive recharge.
Oh, yeah.
It doesn't...
No, I got pulled.
Don't worry.
I have my own shield.
Yo, I'm doing so much damage.
I put it back.
Oh, never mind.
It doesn't care.
Oh, my God.
Yo, crap.
I can come here.
Trying to heal.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Throw me in.
Have a Spider-Man behind us.
Nice, nice, nice.
I think we gotta push up now.
Oh, don't keep it.
We're so healthy.
Kill this guy.
Oh, they ain't moving anywhere.
They ain't going nowhere.
No, they're not.
Oh, they're stuck.
They're stuck.
Oh, they're stuck here.
They're stuck here, guys.
Hey!
Oh, Spider-Man on me.
Spider-Man, I got you.
You know what?
I got you!
Oh, not you though.
I don't got you.
Wallum, Jay, Wallum.
I'm Wallum, bro.
I'm Wallum.
Okay, I don't know what to do now.
That's right.
I've got a shield.
You can't do shit.
I'm getting trolled!
Look, I'm getting trolled!
week oh no oh we're so close to getting that point no
it's better i'm still going john hey i'm coming back i'm coming back i said they're they're walled bro their their rock is walled i can't fight away i'm sorry i was firing at him i got him i got him bro did you get him oh you did not get him i got him i got him i got him nice i'll take that i'll take quite guys don't worry nice nice we got it we just how did you kill him
out of my way chumps i will say the self-shield is crazy broken
oh my god you took so much damage you melted you literally got a lot of damage not good not good by men walk back from that maybe give me up i have all i put a wall down Best I can do for you.
Nice, nice, nice.
I did jump, I did jump.
I wasn't even feeling it, bro.
I wasn't even feeling at all to this.
Yeah.
Oh, that's good, that's good.
He's out.
Oh, big old huge is massive.
It's massive.
It's insane.
He just got res, but it's okay.
It's still pretty big.
Oh, no.
I can't see.
There's a rocket behind you guys.
Oh, there you go.
I'm what, A3.
Oh, you use E.
You can self regen.
No, OK.
I should have done that.
All right.
Hey, like, if you don't use your cards, it regens you passively.
Oh, I need that medical assistance.
Oh, it's here.
I got you.
Oh, yeah.
I'm here.
I'll speed boost you.
There's no more shields.
Oh, I'm dead, man.
I'm dead.
There's no more.
Amish boosting?
I'm here.
Oh, my God.
Les, you're crazy.
The shotgun is super strong right now, Ninja.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't see the two of them.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
So much damage.
I'm all here soon.
Bro, he just, dude, I'm getting bullied and I don't enjoy it.
I'm alting in.
It's fine, we live.
Get all, get all.
Are you guys okay over there?
I got one?
Oh, no, you're not okay.
He's fantastic!
Oh, I got you.
I got you, I got you, Tim!
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
I got you!
Okay, never mind.
I just respond.
I got Spider-Man on these.
Oh, I got you.
I got you, bro.
Oh.
It's about this one.
We have Gambit.
Oh, I got Rocket.
I got Rocket.
I'm going for the wall.
I'm not gonna heal.
Bro, that is so much damage.
Was it fat?
Oh, it's big.
It's most important.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Is it?
I'm just halting.
I don't know if it was a good idea.
Oh, I'm losing.
I got this.
I'm blocking this.
Oh, I've got it.
I'm okay.
I got you.
I'm fine.
I got one.
I'll take it.
I got a healer.
BP, BP, half HP.
I'm on top right.
Oh.
I'm playing Bucky.
Can't stop me.
There's so many things going on.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I ran out of shield.
was like seven dashes into this have they been trip support this entire game yeah they have they have that's why they have okay this makes more sense now they really want you know they really want to win we'll see you guys out i'm gonna hold here all right i
have love for this too i'm I'm only gonna do this.
So they have to push it.
Look at Gambit.
Anyone willing to help?
I'm pushing.
I pulled Gambit back.
I have a fantastic on me.
Yeah, he's wanting.
One of them.
I'm a Rocket and Gambit behind me.
Nice.
Two supports in the back.
Yeah.
The Gambit got raised.
Oh, nice solo.
I'm coming.
I'm with him.
Okay, okay, okay.
Guys, guys, Kurt.
50 seconds that's a really good wall i'm dead oh my god bro that was best i i'm not there it's just doki i'm here i'm here i'm here that's fine they're dying they're dying they're dying right click simulator baby don't worry i'm a rocket i don't have to try anymore i got i got my own here if they try to walk out i'll try to run back i'm almost there right now
I'm all-time.
Oh no.
Oh, we got this.
We get this.
We still got this.
You be dead?
Three dead?
Pick up.
Oh, that was a go beyond.
Oh no, okay.
Um, I hope you guys are picking up my heels.
I'm almost there.
There you go.
Where's the damage?
I think so.
I think you can.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, good.
We already won.
Nice.
Great old, great old.
Let's peel it.
Go fast.
Go, go it, go it, go it.
Oh, dude.
It's massive.
Nice.
There we go.
Great use.
So easy.
I think there's someone on the left side.
Yep, it's BP.
He's half HP.
I do have a res up now.
Nice.
I'm chucking stuff at you guys.
I'm coming over.
Only 60 seconds left.
Yeah, give me the introduction.
Damn.
Oh, I do have a res if anyone dies.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Too many people die.
That's why I don't want to come back.
No, I don't think so.
I'm leaving.
Oh, I'm behind them.
I'm going to get rid of their res again.
So wait, if I, if I E and don't use it, I heal over time.
Yeah, if I E and don't use it, I damage boost over time?
If you press F, you have damage boost over time, yeah.
Is this damage?
It's just just me.
Yeah, it's just you.
It's just you.
I'm behind the whole team, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They'll never know.
There is a Mr. Fantastic on the card.
This guy has rolled off from his team.
He's getting no heals.
Yeah, yeah.
He can't die.
He doesn't need heals.
Good ball, Jay.
I sold it.
I got...
I do have Rez in.
I have Rez in fast.
Yep, I'm helping.
Nice.
I'm Rez.
Thank you, brother.
Good stuff.
I'm going to use mine here.
Yeah, I'll use mine first.
I'll use mine first.
Okay, okay.
I don't think we need it yet.
Maybe that's a monster.
Nice.
Okay.
I'll let you go first, though, for sure.
Yeah, you want to combo?
Later.
We can combo.
I'm going to the top of the ropes, bro.
Top of the ropes.
I'm launching him now.
I see that.
You ready?
Yeah.
The moment they get close.
Here you go.
Throw it to you guys.
That's one.
I'm going to get the introduction.
Oh.
And you guys got it.
You all got it.
Nice.
No.
It's okay.
She's still healing.
She's not.
Oh, she's almost dead.
She's almost dead.
I can't see you guys.
Oh.
Keep pulling me up.
Oh, my God.
You're so healthy.
He's getting spam healed.
I keep out of here for you.
time she's one shot damage boosting you guys nice nice massive damage here oh no i got you too i got you i'll give you one jay you're on card i'm on i'm on i'm on i'm on i'm on i still got you oh they're gonna oh wait wait he has to destroy the rest i built fortnite around this guy he's just getting me nice nice oh i missed that right there yo necros pulled me off on gambit and i double dashed off that was sick i thought you were dead i stopped i was like he's if he's a guy on here i thought i was dead i thought it was good i'm so excited you might have played gambit you want to go uh i can tank my tanking is a little questionable but good stuff you know i have to go penny for this map bro i have to do it oh you're gonna pay me like this is my map on penny in this is gonna be insane i believe you see me i will say i'm gonna try punny one more time here i will say gabby's actually gabby's come i feel like he has such a high ceiling he does definitely has a high ceiling and then you can
protect me oh this is great you can protect my old it's like it's so hard to figure out look at that rollout it's so hard to figure out when to sorry i'll always protect you bro when to use her his f he used to be four and six oh my god he's not because i've been using his e more than his f his f button and it's like it's so scary it's so scary oh my god like Yeah,
I think you get more damage, damage boost.
Look at this tiny setup I got.
Look at this, bro.
Look at this.
Oh, my God.
Look at, it's like a heel wall or a heel path.
Look at my right arm.
Look at my right arm on mag.
Look at it.
Why is it larger than your left arm?
Well, that's all these extra cards.
Dude, are you good?
I think Gambit can work for a duo heel.
I mean, we just did it against three right there, and it was effective.
Oh, yeah, we got check-in rocket.
res heals as well i think it does i went and stood on your vest and i was running faster oh okay oh they have angela all right i'm with you i'm with you ninja that you can't kill you yeah i mean i'm trying to oh my god but he's trying to kill me now flash is on me weak brother what is that movement speed oh she got buffed on the move speed angela yeah there is someone on the blade top watch me they got big nests they got big nests blade in the back wait what he thinks it really strange really really grabbed i got grabbed goodbye oh you're alive you're alive go live I've always played we have numbers we have numbers we can push yeah push push push oh I need heels thank you oh my god yo blade is kind of scary what the Yeah,
his team up went moon night I just thought I'm not going Don't worry, I got this up He might not need it, but I got it Help!
Help!
You're behind a wall!
I got my heel, I got my heel, he got my heel He's holding!
I'm pretty sure he's on a list He can't be Oh my god Play in my webs Keep him alive, keep him alive I got two.
I got two.
He's our main healer now.
Yeah, he got even left.
He'll got point with my web.
Fungi is weak.
Fungi weak.
I need heals for you.
I got you.
I don't want to die.
I'm trying.
I'm coming over.
Coming over.
I'm throwing.
I'm throwing my stuff.
Catch it.
Yes, I got Riz.
I'm off map.
Not for you.
Use my webs.
I'm back.
We're back.
We're fine.
I'm still in forever.
Don't worry.
I'm ripping off the second you open this up.
No, no, no, don't tie.
They're not here yet.
Everything is fine.
I want to do too.
We don't need to.
We live.
That gross one.
Okay, I think the rocket rest definitely heals.
Massive.
Yeah, Laz was standing on and he never died.
Just have it.
I have a turret if you guys back up.
Angela's anti-yield.
Right here, right here, right here.
I can't kill him.
Goodbye, Craigie.
Are you going to live?
Okay.
I'm on a turret.
It has to be.
It's okay.
Oh, you're going.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
You can fight there forever now.
You know what?
Let's stack all the damage.
Yeah, stack it up.
Stack it up.
Oh.
Oh, my back on me.
Only 60 seconds left.
I point, I point.
I'm not a classy week.
See you nine, see nine.
No, that's fine.
It's fine.
We're too careful.
I'm not meeting you, bro.
It's you and me.
Give me like.
Bro.
See, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
I'm telling you.
Tyler's in the battle.
Oh.
What is he doing here?
I got you out of second.
I got you in a second.
Yeah.
I'm a main.
I'm coming back.
I need heals.
I got you.
I think we got you.
I'm getting out.
Jim, come here, come here.
Is it fat?
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, sort of.
I guess.
No.
It's okay.
There's Nate.
Oh, never mind.
Why am I dead before you guys are?
You're doing great.
You're doing great, did you?
This is crazy, bro.
This is crazy.
I'm going to make it.
You have to keep fighting until we hide.
It would actually go crazy into this cop the more I look at it.
Oh my god.
Yo, this is the ace up my sleeve.
You'll never expect it.
It's clobber in time.
If only you were blue, though.
Yeah, I didn't buy the battle pass.
Tyler invited me, and I kind of panicked and locked up and didn't get the battle pass.
That son of a bitch.
Mikey, you good, bro?
No, bro.
Hey, I'm Joey.
I'm Joey.
Dude, are you guys seeing all back?
This mag is doing it.
No, let's go in.
No, that is actually targeted.
It's actually a harassment right here.
Bro, I got so low on this, guys.
I don't know, man.
I got you, bro.
I told you, I'm protected.
Watch this one.
Watch this one on the way you got away.
Thank you for saving my life.
That was a really good bubble.
No.
Can I hold?
I'm saying it.
Nice.
Oh, that's good.
I got one.
Big.
Does thing have more health?
Do I have more base health?
Oh, my God.
Did, oh, that's personal.
That was definitely personal.
right-click someone you steal up to a hundred health oh my god no no that came over
it's okay it's okay oh i kind of was like in that no no there's no such thing as too deep you're so good you're so good you guys see there's no such thing no such thing we're so fine guys i have to mute myself because he's just watching me he knows whatever I'm sponsored.
I don't understand.
How does he know?
And I haven't died yet.
I got you.
I don't want to die.
Oh my god, please, please, please.
You're going to start knocking on my door.
Guys, this is very hard gameplay of me chucking my name.
I got freaking sucked by the healers and pulled.
Okay, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
I've never been vulnerable in my life.
Okay.
Okay, I can't stop healing!
I can't stop healing!
I can't heal you over there!
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Turn up.
It's okay.
We're so fine.
That's next to us.
Okay.
I didn't hit anyone.
I hit the cart.
It's bad.
It's bad though.
I'm bad.
I'm ulting.
Oh my god.
He's got me.
Shielding you off.
Hit me again.
No!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Gambit is very fun, by the way.
Yeah.
Yes.
Super cool character.
Doki, you're so good.
no no you're so good that is no i fit it first yeah okay look at the aura in the 70s by the way hard hard the dad debuff so much holy oh my gosh bro cool guys look at explosions damn damn daniel back at it again with the white vans look at that guys we beat triple support guys even with all this is the answer to that with the anti-heal and how much damage and stuff you do too that's true that's true like he's his support though oh but you're saying we went do yeah yeah yeah you're like duo was beating trio triple there are we doing this wheel thing what time is oh yeah so five minutes we're five minutes to do one wheel i think but it's a full match wait is it i mean 20 it says i mean maybe do we just do one we do one a cough map yeah i'm down each player will spin the random choose hero wheel to determine their hero after you die you need to spin again to choose a new one play two matches oh that's a lot i think we can play i mean why i'm down with the timing of it one maybe one round
on cough yeah send it yeah i believe you're coming we can spin the wheel every time you die yeah yes do get it do you get a new one all right i'm spinning that right now i'm spinning it i'm spinning it so hard here we go i i have to spin i'm rocky raccoon i what Almost the Punisher,
bro.
I feel like just playing action.
I am in this woman.
You know, guys, I have to play Blade, and I've never played a game on Blade.
See, maybe they also have to play Blade.
You'll be fine, bro.
All right, here we go.
So when you die, you spin again.
That's how this works.
Guys, I might have gotten Hella.
Oh, no.
It's over.
Do not die.
You don't die.
yeah all right wow we got this guys we don't need anyone get a tank do we have any yeah i'm the thing oh okay thank god okay we got one if you don't want that you don't want that though that's not good wow we actually have a kind of a cop yeah we have two two three one love it do we win this unless they troll tyler is solo tanking on the thing bro really i'm screwed just right click spam you get shield off and it's sick yo yo thinkmates are gonna eat this update bro we're eating the vulnerability is so nuts when you jump in there oh yeah yeah the new buffer they get easier to kill now yeah it's like 25 bonus damage 25 okay that's he needed something like that bro yeah that's true but that's crazy 25 you can No,
I'm not crazy, right?
This shield's bigger, right?
On Invis?
Yeah, it is.
It's only the self-shield, though.
I'm pretty sure it's the same.
No, no, you put it on someone else.
Like, if you put the right click on someone, it's small.
No, that's the F.
That is not average.
That's the F one.
All right, so my E, I basically just want to run around in E form, right?
Basically.
No, your shotgun does great damage.
That medium range.
It's not a close, though.
It's not enough close.
How do I do my anti-channel?
I can't believe Craigie got Hella, bro.
your shift on your shotgun mode you shift into them and then you have to actually aim it okay I believe okay okay you never die a bunch of flyers yeah right wait they get all flyers there's no way they got iron man ultra bro watch the roots play it's okay if we kill the blade there's no res by the way there's no I have to I have to spin I'm spinning yo I'm going up I'm gonna hit an E I'm going up wait they have no tanks we have they have no tanks we win this I spin yeah guys guys good morning Ninja we got you oh my god we have two tanks now let's go we're now coming I can kind of play this guy oh wait wait wait he's so he's so healthy I'm actually so good though yeah don't worry Craigie we'll never let you die we don't know about last though oh no I'm sorry he's dead he's dead oh no we are carries dead our carries did
oh god oh guys you guys are gonna guess what I got next what what when's your soldier oh that's crazy yeah I'm getting like no i just got my arm okay i'm spinning i'm spinning i'm spinning nice i'm scared i don't want to die on i'm not dying bro i'm not dying i got no more guys i got jeff why am i please this is perfect coming over trying to run i'm literally trying to run i'm the old tech oh black widow good luck reported i'm Oh,
no.
Oh, no.
We're okay.
Everything's fine.
I have bubbles for you.
I got Magneto.
I got Mag.
Oh, my God.
You're cheating.
It's over.
We're slowly becoming meta.
I'm going for flank boys.
Yeah.
Don't see me.
We have a widow without her, without the Phoenix.
And it's last was on widow, which I've never in my life.
I believe it.
So you've seen this.
You don't know.
I'm getting solo ulted.
Some of you trolling.
I'm actually getting trolled.
I got solo ulted.
You're hitting every shot.
I've never played Daredevil.
I got Daredevil.
I believe, I believe.
Oh, my God.
This is going to be terrible.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Never mind.
This movement is insane.
I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're alive.
You're alive.
I love you too.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Yeah.
I'm running out.
Bye.
I'm dead.
That was their hello.
That's my bad.
Oh, I have no idea.
I have no idea.
I needed to get off that character immediately.
That was terrible.
Here's the thing.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I'm being followed everywhere.
You got thing?
Okay.
This is good.
You're spinning the wheel.
I'm waiting for whoever comes out.
I'm waiting.
Wait, nobody came out.
Wait, it's Widow.
They have Widow.
She doesn't know I'm right behind her.
She's so stupid.
I have no idea what's happening.
I just popped my freaking healing.
We got points.
Oh my god.
I just drank this already.
Yes!
I'm spinning.
What did I get?
Okay, I got Wolverine.
All right, this is...
Oh, huge.
I don't know.
I'm going to be zoning.
I have to walk back.
I'm going to be a zoner.
We are only healers low-key right now.
Oh, my God.
I didn't say it.
He didn't.
I should probably heal you guys.
Yeah, yeah, my back.
Just copy, cloak.
Crackers.
You got to copy their cloak from you.
I got you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God, they have Gambit all too.
Cranky, Massimo!
Where are you all in my attack too?
Good game, good!
It's over, I'm done, I'm done, I'm done!
Someone roll it, get strange!
Are we winning?
No, we are not!
I'm gonna roll strange!
I'm Luna!
I said, I said I got Bruce, I didn't get Hulk, so does that mean I never Hulk?
Wait, you just never?
What, does that?
I said, Bruce!
Is there even Hulk in there?
It said Bruce!
Oh my god, we're cooked.
There's no way Bruce is an option on this wheel, right?
No way?
It says Bruce Banner.
Oh my god.
There's literally no hook in the wheel.
I got Captain America.
I got Adam Boyle.
It says Bruce.
I'm going by the rules.
Alright, it's time.
The best Bruce in the world.
Okay, am I the only healer?
Wait, me?
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
We have Adam.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is a composition is insane.
Just get on the point.
Yo, we got to get Craigie set up on the point and we can just all stand in the webs and heal.
This could actually work really well.
I'll do bond for us too.
I don't really know.
I mean, I know.
Wait, what's my C?
What is this?
Life's deal.
Oh, yeah, it does life's deal.
Yeah, it's a team up.
It's a team up.
So like, if you're a doe, buy someone you use, you press C and then you get your heals back where you can hit them.
But you got to hit them.
Jay, how many hours you got on Hulk, bro?
Hours?
give me minutes oh wait you can see like space on the adam skin i'm giving you flake tyler hell yeah bro i'm going in yeah no you need to you know i'm going captain america yeah get set up yeah get set up we all need all the web stuff wait wait where's our where's our penny nest no no the thing in the middle went down i'm dead oh i just i just tried to hit
I'm dead.
It's over.
They all...
Wait, I can rest?
I have to spin.
Alright, I'm dead.
I got bad news for this team, bro.
Guys, you don't understand.
I do not...
It's okay.
Maybe, well, I'm Hawkeye.
No, this is good.
No, this is over.
I got Bucky.
That's actually it's over, bro.
I have win over.
I think it's over.
We have zero supports now.
really weak to be killer get her craggy it's fine i could there's no way they have triple support with random spin okay yeah right they are not spitting there's no way they i got one of them please surely we can kill one of the supports i i can't do it bro i'm dead i'm shooting again i killed that cross no no no no i got blade again it's good we got one support We got support.
We got support.
I just died.
Enjoy, bro.
Guys, it's okay.
We got support, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Please, give me something I play.
Rock your raccoon!
Oh, I got it.
All right, guys.
We have support.
That's all we need.
Wait.
They have hella though, so a little scared.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm going in.
life steal.
Where is my life steal when I'm attacked?
Don't worry, you guys.
If you die, I'll save you from holding.
Oh, my God.
What am I doing?
Guys, I have Hawkeye again.
Where is Hawkeye?
I got Thor again.
My years away from the Avengers taught me how much they meant to me.
Do you guys see this?
Look at the gambit.
He's five.
We have res.
Oh, we gotta go to the point here.
It's okay.
Oh, I'm dead.
i'm going to point i'm going to point with my own i think i can touch can you touch i have my i'm all here i can throw it on point i might be able to touch oh my touch okay i guess you guys got this i'm coming over but i'm mistaken i just got pushed off the map i've there's a hell of right behind us right here i'm dead bro it's all over ben i got black I'm coming back.
I'm coming back fast.
Please give me Dr. Strange report.
No Starlord, I think I have 10 minutes on this guy.
Oh my oh my the pain will be over soon, but I'm dead I only got to do is spin Dr. Strange I got moon night
Look I'm saying they spun the wheel and got triple support.
I don't I don't buy that bro There's nothing we could do.
I don't buy that they spun the tank off of it He got a real cop.
It's not our fault.
Yeah, we won the games that matter, guys.
We did.
Yeah.
We didn't think we won the games that people were trying on their characters on.
Exactly.
That gross even went Spider-Man and we still won.
Several times.
Oh, that's a win, bro.
I'm going to go put that down on my journal later tonight, dude.
That's right.
All right, guys.
It's been a blast.
I'm going to show it.
the battle pass one more time and i'm gonna call it ggs ggs everyone ggs bye-bye yeah it's nice seeing you too fair oh it's so fun i had so much fun it's always fun playing with these guys yeah dude today i want to get necros on spider-man yeah thank you everyone thank you everyone that was really fun i can't that stopped barking he stopped barking When it was like,
oh, you're not trying anymore.
I'm not going to bother you.
I'm like, are you fucking kidding me?
I'm good.
It was like, oh, wait.
Like, y'all, wait.
That game's over.
I'm leaving.
He knows.
I told you.
He fucking knows when I'm, like, in an intense game.
He knows.
And then we're here to fuck around.
We're losing.
And he's like, I'm not bothering you.
I'm not going to bother you now.
Anyway, I hope you guys enjoyed the season 5 preview.
I guess I also showed up Battle Pass.
Jorn got stealing his idea.
But let's see.
Here is the Battle Pass for those who want to see it.
Here's the cool-ass skin and the intro.
And then there's Groot.
And then there's...
I like this highlight intro.
I'm not like a huge fan of...
I mean, I think the Frankencast was pretty good.
But I like the highlight intro in general for Frankencast.
I think it's really cool.
and um yeah I think I like the idea that he's breaking out of the TV it's like 3d shit and this one's my favorite he's blue what if the thing was blue what
what if he was blue it was wild what if he was blue um anyway guys uh please make sure to check out mob arrivals season 5 on November 14th um like I said please click on the link pinned in my chat or in the panel it really does help out stream a lot huge shout out again to marvel rivals devs for sponsoring me uh for the early access i really appreciate it as a vtuber representation um in the in um in the uh early access preview group um it does mean a lot it's such a huge honor um as always when they uh when they ask me to do these things um and you know i get to play with a lot of really cool people too uh but yeah the game is always updating it is free to play remember all heroes are free to play you don't there's no special requirement And there's always new updates coming in non-stop,
too.
But thank you, everyone.
Thank you for all the subs, the bitties, the follows, the raids.
Thank you, everyone, for the raid.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to thank you guys for the raid because I was so in the zone for the early access preview because it was that, you know, it was sponsored, so I had to make sure I got everything.
I know some people were asking me because Iron Mouse and Sea Dog announced a VTuber Rivals Cup, and you're like, oh, are you in it?
I asked the devs, like, oh, can I be in it?
and they're like, yeah, you're in.
So, um, from what I know, I'm in.
I don't have any details yet.
Like, I didn't have, I wasn't sent anything yet, but the devs told me that I'm in the VTuber, uh, rivalous thing.
That's all I know.
Like, they just told me that I'm in it.
I wasn't sent any, like, invite or any more details.
They just said I'm in it.
Like, so, Gambit is definitely, I think I played Gambit too much, like, a healer.
I feel like I had to play him, I have like more for for like damage as well um so gabbit was very hard to juggle in terms of like you have your mind has to be like on 24 7 because like you gotta know your research you have to do really good resource management and you have to play both like be able to balance both styles seems really really difficult just because like you know you have to know when to use the anti-heal or like the vulnerability one because he does the vulnerability too um like the for the damage card he either has vulnerability or anti-heal so you gotta be able to balance the two and the cleanse too yeah like you gotta be able to um know when to use the heal and when you need to use the cleanse too because you know you have to reflex the cleanse as well um so it is very apparently i was told that his cleanse can cancel Groot ult if you time it correctly so like that's crazy like that can negate an entire Groot ult if you time it correctly though only if you time it can
do that uh yeah so that's what i was told so um maybe i'm spreading fake news you guys can try it out too but uh yeah that's a whole team fight uh deny but i was told that um so um you guys can try it out yourselves later on the 14th um and you guys can see how freaking strong it is um it was in the trailer oh it was in the trailer yeah in the trailer he cleansed the grudal basically no that's crazy that's scary that's a entire team fight god you're right you're that's very scary hey guys if you guys want to check me out more um please feel free to follow me on twitter i usually announce whenever i'm streaming on uh whenever i'm streaming on twitch on twitter or if i have like sponsors like this on twitter um they want if you enjoy my content please follow me on youtube because that's where i usually do my mainstreaming stuff um like i said YouTube is my main platform so please check me out on YouTube um um you can see in chat the commands are all there um to check me out there
subscribing to me on YouTube um it wants to support me via other means I have a lot of merch going on right now I have a controller collab if you guys want to or like guys look at this whoa guys look at look okay sorry not yet not yet let me grab the picture look at this guys whoa I have my very own controller whoa but yeah if free to pre-order the controller it really does help out a lot it is a very cool merch um you know very rare opportunity to get you know for vtuber you get their own like controller design and everything and you know enough if we get enough sales maybe we can do other controllers soon instead of just you know a playstation controller so um yeah please feel free to pre-order controllers only out for a month um it's only the pre-order is only out for a month and everything so it really does help support a lot um and i have other merch too on the store you guys want to check out my merch store just do exclamation point merch and you check out my merch store it does
Does support me a lot.
Anyway, guys, I think that's everything all the show I have to do.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.